the foundation regularly deals with
anomalies of a more sinister nature the
most frightening among these of course
are the ones that stalk and kill
foundation operatives for no clear rhyme
or reason sometimes the foundation's
agents and researchers become subject to
things that seek to entrap and utterly
consume them dr elizabeth graham is one
such poor soul nowadays her name is
whispered through mess halls and
cubicles since no one really seems to
know what happened to her one moment she
was carrying a stack of files between
two offices the next completely gone the
foundation's security teams couldn't
figure out what happened to her the cctv
cameras just showed her blinking out of
existence and the files falling to the
floor her biometric scanners simply
returned a dead signal it seemed that
one day dr graham simply ceased to exist
of course the foundation isn't above
keeping secrets from its own personnel
perhaps they did find something a series
of scp documents covered in sand
suddenly appearing in graham's office
one day neatly stacked and paper clipped
all signed by her in her own handwriting
and detailing her days spent in a pocket
reality of some sort it wouldn't be the
first time it had happened the infamous
red reality incident with dr robert
scranton had already upset researchers
and there was no reason to alarm them
further about something they couldn't
change so dr graham's papers were
covered up and relegated to long-term
storage where they would likely never be
thought of again but don't you wonder
what happened to dr graham the first
thing dr graham felt when she woke up
was confusion she didn't remember
falling asleep in fact she didn't
remember much at all she had been moving
files between two offices at site 22 on
a normal workday she said hello to some
of her co-workers and had a late lunch
before returning to work and then
nothing the second thing she felt was
fear she looked around and realized she
was in some kind of desert a bright blue
sky was overhead and there seemed to be
a sun but all around her was sand
massive sand dunes flowing sand planes
and even what looked like a sandstorm in
the distance but all there was was sand
dr graham then noticed she was still
holding some things a small folder
filled with paperclip documents pulling
one out she realized what it was a
template document for an scp file
complete with sections for object class
containment procedures and descriptions
this place was obviously not normal but
she had been anomalously transported to
it it needed to be documented there was
nothing else to do so she sat down and
began to write she guests at a number
who knows what scp the foundation was on
now might as well pick something for the
middle she scrawled
scp-3890 at the top and bubbled in
ketter for the object class the
containment procedures were spartan but
effective no effective measures of
containment were possible and she would
focus on simply exploring and finding
out what was going on then came the
description no point in sticking to the
foundation's signature clinical tone
given the circumstances it was more
important to get the information down
and so she began to transcribe her
thoughts
scp-3890 is a potentially
extra-dimensional or extraterrestrial
space which i dr elizabeth graham was
somehow transported to from site 22 on 2
17 16. i'm uncertain as to whether i was
transported here due to my involvement
with the foundation after finishing the
paragraph she picked herself up off the
sand dune she had landed on and started
to walk in the direction of the sun she
didn't have much information and
exploring would be necessary if she was
to accurately document the anomaly it
didn't take long before she came across
something in the distance an old
collapsed temple completely ruined from
the outside the structure sagging in on
itself it had the columns and facades of
a roman building she noticed peering
inside it was completely empty except
for more sand in the distance more ruins
were present some older and some more
modern office looking buildings in terms
of geography
scp-3890 takes the form of a seemingly
infinite desert plane with ruins of
differing architectural design poking
out through the sand i have noted the
presence of buildings of modern design
along with what appear to be ruins of
ancient roman and eriksen structures she
only noticed the first figure when the
sun started to set as the sky shifted to
twilight she saw a person walking
casting a long shadow excitedly she
yelled out to no response when she
approached she saw a man in an older
suit with completely lifeless eyes
stumbling along
scp-3890-1 is my collective designation
for the humanoid entities that wander
through
scp-3890 they do not respond to any
stimuli and as far as i've been able to
tell simply walk around without a
specific destination
scp-3890-1 are either entities that have
been created to resemble humans but
imperfect or they are humans who have
been mentally altered in some way to rob
them of their faculties there did seem
to be some kind of a day night cycle and
she didn't feel hungry or thirsty at all
though she did feel sleepy after her
first day in the desert dr graham
settled in one of the collapsed ruins
drifting off to sleep the second
document opens much differently this
appears to be a document for something
designated
scp-3890-2 ketter the containment
procedures are simply to always
constantly be on guard for it whatever
it is if dr graham feels something she
is approaching is not as it appears she
is to immediately retreat the
description is a little clearer
scp-3890-2 is a living entity of varying
shape and size which resides in scp-3890
i am uncertain as to whether
scp-3890-2 originates here or if it was
transported here at some point in the
same way i was from what i have observed
of its behavior it appears to be some
form of predator
scp-3890-2 is currently hunting me i
first encountered the entity shortly
after writing down my initial
observations of scp-3890
it snuck up behind me while i was
resting and got me while i wasn't paying
attention i was knocked unconscious by
its attack and woke up several hours
later during the night it had attacked
me several times since that first
encounter with several hours between
each attack she was caught off guard by
it last night she hadn't noticed its
presence it seemed to just be another
building in the far off horizon when she
sat down and pulled out her pencil and
paper again she had started to fill in
some more information about the
humanoids they seemed to continuously
walk in circles around some of the ruins
though it was unclear to her why or even
whether they were aware of what they
were doing but when she pulled her
pencil out she heard the buzzing in her
head it was like tv static initially
soft and low but then ramping up and
quickly becoming deafening stifling her
ability to think she looked up and she
saw it for a moment it retained its form
as the building in the horizon but that
quickly changed it began to unfold on
itself completely black on the inside
like a dark paper crane continually
folding and unfolding stretching and
compressing in on itself by the time dr
graham got to her feet and ran away she
began to realize what it had done and
quickly scrawled it onto the paper
scp-3890-2 uses amnestization as a form
of attack while it has not injured me
physically thus far i've lost all memory
of significant chunks of my childhood
and early adulthood i can no longer
recall which high school i went to or
what my first job was my current
hypothesis is that as an entity it feeds
upon memory at first dr graham avoided
buildings and stayed to the empty parts
of the desert while walking but when the
creature appeared again unfolding out of
what seemed to be a piece of paper it
became clear what it was a mimic in the
coming hours it would pretend to be a
star a human a fly even a patch of dirt
while trying to make graham come closer
enough to consume her mind the next
document opens in even more dire
circumstances the containment procedures
have shifted drastically containment now
focuses on making sure that the mimic
does not consume any memories that dr
graham cannot afford to lose she is to
write down all vital memories so she can
recall them if they do get destroyed and
watch for its presence in situations and
at all times she writes the document
while huddled in a vault in a bank
dropped into scp-3890
since it offers a little security from
the creature but the corpses of a family
in the bank imply something less hopeful
they chose to die by their own hand
rather than let the mimic get to them
graham plans to kill anything that tries
to enter the vault to ensure that the
mimic doesn't get in but has bigger
problems i have lost all memories
regarding how i came to be employed by
the foundation i know that i am a
foundation researcher with level 3
clearance but i simply cannot recall how
i came to be in this position many of
the scp objects i worked with are also
missing from my memory i can tell there
is a hole there but i just don't know
what was there before her memories of
her own identity have been obliterated
who she is where she's from what the
foundation even is they have all been
taken by the mimic without fail it
manages to surprise her and consume an
important memory then dashing away as
she tries to figure out what got stolen
from her something small like her
favorite food or her childhood bedroom
or something foundational and
fundamental like her name and her sense
of self and avoiding it isn't an option
it can pretend to be any of the single
grains of sand in the boundless desert
and graham came to the conclusion this
is an infinite dimension of sand serving
as a hunting grounds for the mimic of
course it could be anything else too a
brick a window any of the buildings any
of the mindless wandering people or the
clothes on dr graham's back any of them
could be the mimic and graham thought of
that too it's why she hasn't let go of
her knife in days even though it's
dripping blood from examining the
corpses of the former victims of
scp-3890-2
even though she doesn't need to eat or
drink there is another concern sleep the
moment she falls asleep the mimic will
no doubt be upon her she hastily
scribbled down a little bit more onto
the paper before trying to rest the
sun's going down i can't allow myself to
fall asleep
3890-2 will come in without a doubt if i
do i don't have to eat i don't have to
drink but i still have to sleep this
place is designed for the mimic's
benefit it can hunt its prey to its
heart's content without them dying of
thirst and starvation is this an
enclosure maybe some kind of sick game
my name is elizabeth graham i can't
forget that now this page is my memory
the next word she writes on that paper
shows something ominous she can hear
crying outside of her makeshift shelter
the next document things have changed
someone named tony is mentioned in the
containment procedures someone graham
trusts to take watch while she sleeps
and watches for the mimic the
descriptions explain tony is a child
only 10 years old who fell into this
dimension the same as graham when
walking home from the playground the
mimic can imitate objects but it can't
speak the boy is real they've worked on
a rudimentary password system to confirm
each other's identities regardless
graham feels almost hopeful their
chances of survival have doubled even
though they're being hunted not for
their lives but for the precious
memories inside their heads but she's
still worried about other things if
people don't starve or thirst to death
in scp-3890
do they age how long have the mindless
humanoids been wandering around how long
has she been wandering around though she
reminds herself of her training she also
faces the fact that she might have been
exclusively picked for a past reason i
have this memory from my childhood still
everything around it is gone but it's
sort of floating free devoid of context
i'm visiting a woman in the hospital i i
think it's a hospital and i think it's a
woman i know a close relative my mother
or my grandmother i think and i go to
visit her i'm just a kid 12 i think and
she doesn't know who i am at all i don't
remember what happened before that or
after perhaps the mimic brought her here
because it knew she would hate having
her mind consumed like this but that
would mean it wasn't just intelligent
that it was sadistic and cruel she noted
down she'd asked tony if he had a
similar experience and they'd be a
little closer to working it out the
document is hopeful dr graham now has
something to believe in the next
document is a complete mess scribblings
and scrawlings in the margins and the
text doesn't even begin to make any kind
of sense it's all word salad the ravings
of someone gone utterly insane she
mentions herself her own name repeatedly
and constantly but in between are
mentions of tony the foundation the
mimic and everything in between dr
graham has lost her grip on reality that
or whatever wrote this wasn't dr
elizabeth graham the document after that
has a very simple containment procedures
she is to kill scp-3890-2
the mimic description i woke up this
morning tony was gone he was the mimic
he was smarter than i thought i guess i
was stupid i should have seen this
coming but i was desperate and it knew
it all it left was some scrawled
document in a hole in my head the shape
of my name the mimic disguising itself
as a child had stolen the last thing she
had left her name all of graham's
precautions were useless even though her
name was written down a dozen times in
the last documentation she cannot
remember it in fact when she reads it it
immediately removes itself from her mind
again not only has it taken her memory
it has taken her ability to reform them
and the documented left behind is one of
her own an scp template though of course
she doesn't know what the foundation is
anymore the same document we have seen
previously in the pile yes the mimic is
learning to imitate graham and getting
better at it maybe that's why she hasn't
been killed yet it's yet to pin down her
thought process and is waiting until it
has her perfectly memorized not that she
would know given that she's forgotten
how she even came here or when
but the mimic made a mistake it took
everything from her even her hope which
has left dr elizabeth graham a woman
with nothing left to lose she resolves
she will not get out of scp-3890
the documents will probably wind back up
in foundation possession from some
testing with an unrelated anomaly but
she will be a mindless husk or worse she
plans to kill the mimic it's a cowardly
fearful stalker creature and only hunts
by pretending to be other things she
knows she can take it in a fight and she
still has her knife the next document is
sober the object class neutralized dr
graham walked boundlessly through the
desert until the mimic jumped for her it
unfolded from a cloud turning into a
mass of black origami and lunging for
her it didn't expect her to turn around
and slash outward with her knife
piercing its strange black flesh it let
out a scream shrank and dr graham
realized that it could feel pain so when
it lunged again she drove her knife
deeper into it before pulling back and
she repeated the process until it was a
tiny black mite in the sand and then she
crushed it under her heel it was that
easy that simple but of course every
time it had come close to her it had
taken another bite out of her mind just
as she took another slash at its form we
opened each other up i filled its body
with holes and it filled my mind with
them there's not much left of me she
curses herself from not having done it
earlier but maybe there was a reason she
can't remember it anymore in any case
the mimics dying bites from her were
particularly damaging the straw that
broke the camel's back what's left of dr
elizabeth graham is falling apart she
scribbles things down onto the paper
while her mind realizes that she can't
even understand what she's writing
anymore the next document is empty not
every story with the foundation's agents
fighting a monster has a happy ending
now go check out scp-3001 red reality
and
scp-3838 nomads of the fourth
dimensional step for more otherworldly
dimension-related scps